stellt euch das mal vor während wir hier
alle noch brav auf unsere erste impfung
warten geht wahrscheinlich das
altersheim bald schon wieder auf tour
die frisch geimpften 80 ich habe nicht
den eindruck dass diejenigen die jetzt
grad zuerst geimpft werden die höchst
betagten und die beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen das deren erste frage
jetzt ist ob sie wieder in den club
dürfen vielleicht fliegen ja die ersten
ostern schon wieder nach malle weil sie
da schon den eintrag im imf ausweis
vorzeigen können und der lufthansa-chef
hat ja schon angekündigt dass zumindest
auf langstreckenflügen künftig jeder
passagier entweder getestet oder
geimpftes wir haben so wenig geimpfte
damit wird die lufthansa kann und pflege
erfüllen können da hat er recht der herr
lauterbach aber wenn selbst der
aussenminister schon fordert geimpfte
sollen wieder ins restaurant dürfen dann
müssen wir darüber reden
[Musik]
ich bin christian hübscher vom zdf
hauptstadtstudio und wer hätte das mal
gedacht dass ausgerechnet dieses kleine
gelbe heftchen das man ja eigentlich
immer er sucht wenn man es mal braucht
das diesmal so wichtig werden könnte
klar im moment ist das noch eine
phantomdebatte aber alle politiker
zerbrechen sich gerade den kopf wie man
das regeln könnte wenn irgendwann mal
eine kritische masse wirklich geimpft
ist müssen die weiter maske tragen sich
an quarantäne regeln halten dürfen die
vielleicht sogar früher wieder ins kino
und würdet ihr das fair finden jens
spahn der gesundheitsminister verspricht
seit wochen es werde jedenfalls von
staatlicher seite keine sonderrechte für
geimpfte gegen aus meiner sicht sollte
es auf gar keinen fall eine solche
unterscheidung wie gesagt bei
daseinsvorsorge geben öffentlicher
personennahverkehr zum beispiel
krankenhaus wer zugang zum
gesundheitswesen
dort kann ich mir eine solche
unterscheidung überhaupt nicht
vorstellen aber herr spahn in der
aktuellen hessischen quarantäne
verordnungen hier steht genau das längst
drin moment in hessen müssen all die
nicht mehr in quarantäne die aus einem
risikogebiet zurückkehren und 14 tage
vor einreise über eine vollständig
abgeschlossene schutz impfung gegen das
virus verfügen was ist das jetzt anders
als eine staatliche bevorzugung von
geimpften einfach mal in hessen
nachfragen ersparen steht längst alles
drin in offiziellen verlautbarungen
einer den das gerede über privilegien
echt aufregt es wird kein kubicki von
der fdp wir haben ja die und rechts
einschränkungen vorgenommen
wegen der ansteckungsgefahr und dem
schutz des gesundheitssystems werden von
den geimpften keine ansteckungsgefahr
ausgehe
sind sie von verfassungs wegen ihre
grundrechte wieder einzusetzen ich
verstehe die diskussion ich wenn herr
spannend sagt das dürfe keine
privilegien geben die
verfassungsrechtslage nicht begriffen er
hat auf jeden fall recht was das wording
angeht also lasst uns nicht mehr von
sonderrechten oder privilegien reden es
sind grundrechte und kubicki spricht
hier gleich noch was wichtiges an wir
können überhaupt erst über sowas wie
lockerungen für geimpfte nachdenken wenn
wir sicher wissen dass man trotz impfung
das virus nicht munter weiter verteilen
kann also weiter ansteckend bleibt und
bis dahin sieht auch die kanzlerin
überhaupt keinen diskussionsbedarf wir
wissen nicht ob der geimpfte nicht
trotzdem andere anstecken kann diese
frage ist noch nicht geklärt und solange
nicht geklärt ist stellt sich diese
frage der privilegien überhaupt noch
nicht aber vorausgesetzt wir wissen bald
geimpfte sind nicht mehr ansteckend oder
zumindest nicht mehr so stark dann sind
grundrechts beschränkungen für alle
quasi mit dem rasenmäher passiert das
hat mir auch die justizministerin sehr
deutlich gesagt beschränken zurzeit
freiheits und grundrechte der
bürgerinnen und bürger sehr weitgehend
ein
und wir müssen als staat immer genau
begründen warum das erforderlich warum
das verhältnismäßig ist um leib und
leben zu schützen das ist die begründung
wenn das nicht mehr der fall ist wenn
also keine gefahr mehr ausgehen kann
dann kann es auch keine begründung geben
um grundrechte einzuschränken
und diese diskussion werden wir führen
die diskussion wird munter denn darüber
besteht ja nicht mal innerhalb der spd
einigkeit vor kurzem noch haben die
genossen sogar darüber nachgedacht eine
solche bevorzugung über ein
verbotsgesetz regelrecht zu verbieten
davon ist die spd ist zwar offenbar
wieder abgekommen aber stimmen wie ihn
hier gibt es immer noch viele ich halte
gar nichts davon zu sagen wie mit einem
windhundrennen dass die die jetzt nun
das glück
zuerst geimpft worden zu sein dass die
dann auch wirklich wieder dinge in
anspruch nehmen können und andere nicht
die bisher einfach die möglichkeiten
noch nicht hatten insofern bin ich auch
gegen so eine ungleichbehandlung alle
menschen sind vor dem gesetz gleich das
sagt artikel 3 im grundgesetz aber der
privatwirtschaft wird der staat wohl
nicht vorschreiben können alle menschen
gleich zu behandeln denn
privatunternehmen konnten sich schon
immer aussuchen wen sie ihre dienste
anbieten und wem nicht das kennen wir ja
alle von der tür vom nachtclub lavo auch
der türsteher entscheidet wer rein darf
und wer nicht auch eine kreuzfahrt nur
für geimpfte wäre also dran dass private
anbieter das ist ein kreuzfahrt
unternehmen anbieten können ich mache
eine kreuzfahrt aber nur mit wenigen von
denen definitiv keine gefahr mehr
ausgehen kann weil geimpfte und bei
nicht mehr infektiös halte ich für
selbstverständlich gehört alles andere
wäre auch nicht zurecht nicht
zurückdrehen und der kriegt herr kubicki
inzwischen auch immer mehr unterstützung
von verfassungsrechtlern wie zum
beispiel steffen augsburg der es
professor für öffentliches recht an der
uni gießen und zudem auch mitglied im
ethikrat der erde auch ein wichtiges
wörtchen mitzureden hat private können
prinzipiell willkürlich entscheiden mit
wem sie verträge schließen mit dem sie
also ins geschäft kommen wollen
und dann gibt es kleinere ausnahmen die
im allgemeinen gleichbehandlungsgesetz
geregelt sind wo zum beispiel dann
festgehalten wird dass behinderung oder
religion oder ethnische herkunft für
diese vertragsbeziehung keinen
unterschied machen darf im übrigen
bleibt es bei den privaten dabei dass
sie sich entsprechend frei entscheiden
können der staat hingegen ist stärker an
differenzierungs verbote gebunden
braucht also für seine
ungleichbehandlung jeweils einen
sachlichen grund denken wir zum beispiel
an aigle clubs restaurants
fußballstadien theaterbühnen hier
pamela vom berliner club gretchen das
ist einer der bekannten clubs in berlin
seit letztem märz geschlossen gibt es
bei ihr bald clubnächte nur für geimpfte
pamela sagt mir im interview sie denkt
darüber nach aber sicher ist sie sich
auch nicht
ich finde wirklich es ist eine
schwierige debatte
also ich kann mir ich für mich ich
spreche jetzt aber tatsächlich für mich
und nicht für die gesamte kultur weil
das wird es wirklich sehr sehr
kontrovers diskutiert ich kann mir das
schon vorstellen dass man dass man
sozusagen eine app hat wo man dann vor
zeigt dass man geimpft ist wir haben ja
im club betrieb und im konzertbetrieb ja
auch so sachen wie vor verkaufstheke zum
beispiel da muss man ja auch ein ticket
vorzeigen und das muss man eben mit
bringen entweder man hat das irgendwie
digital auf dem handy oder man druckt es
aus also rein technisch quasi wäre die
kontrolle von solchen dingen nicht das
problem aber es ist natürlich schwierig
weil das weil es irgendwie so durch die
hintertür quasi so eine verpflichtung
mit sich bringt man muss das tun um das
machen zu können und dann müsste ich
noch länger drüber diskutieren auch mit
mir selber ob ich das jetzt gut finde
oder nicht aber seien wir mal ehrlich es
wird dauern bis sich das finanziell für
privatunternehmen lohnt es wird ewig
dauern bis es genügend geimpfte gibt die
wieder in den club wollen der kontrolle
auch wann könnte viel zu groß sein und
das öffentliche feedback zu negativ von
wegen man darf ja nur noch am
kulturellen leben teilnehmen wenn man
geimpft ist aber von dem impfzwang durch
die hintertür könne keine rede sein sagt
jedenfalls der verfassungsrechtler
augsburg dass man vorteile an einen
bestimmten impfstatus knüpft von
privater seite aus ist sicherlich kein
zwang ist ein wenn sie so wollen ein
matching ein privates oder 1 1 schubsen
in diese richtung was aber kein zwang
bedeutet
die israelis zb impfen ja wie die
weltmeister und dort wird der staat ganz
offensiv damit den geimpften wieder
freiheiten einzuräumen die freiheit zu
reißen zb mit einem so genannten grünen
pass dazu hat unser israel korrespondent
einen kleinen feinen gemacht den
verlinken wir euch am ende nochmal und
dass man bei einreise irgendwo eine
impfung vorweisen muss das hat ja auch
schon immer gegeben denkmal an die
gelbfieberimpfung ohne die könnt ihr in
viele länder südamerikas oder afrika es
gar nicht rein
aber das findet irgendwie niemand
diskriminierend wir werden also auch
darüber reden müssen wird der impfpass
zum reisepass die griechen zum beispiel
wollen das klar die brauchen die
touristen zurück premierminister
mitsotakis hat schon einen brief an die
eben kommissionspräsidentin von der
leyen geschrieben und darin fordert er
menschen die geimpft sind sollten freier
reisen dürfen
und mir zu tag hat auch gleich angehängt
wie er sich so ein impf dokument
vorstellt nämlich eben nicht hier mit
diesem altmodischen gelben impfausweis
der ja wahrscheinlich auch nicht
fälschungssicher ist und wo zum beispiel
bei mir noch eine adresse drauf steht
die gar nicht mehr geld sondern
natürlich elektronisch mit einem qr code
in der ecke der dargestellt wird bei der
einreise und es gibt auch in brüssel
wichtige deutsche stimmen die genau das
fordern reisefreiheit für geimpfte wenn
jemand geimpft ist da gibt es eigentlich
nur noch wenige gründe ihm abzusprechen
dass es eine rechte wieder voll in
anspruch nimmt wir wollen wieder zurück
zum normalen leben und die die impfen
die sich entschlossen sondern auch den
vorteil davon haben
und worüber man hier auch nochmal
nachdenken muss was ist eigentlich mit
den kindern die er dann mit ihren
geimpften eltern reisen wollen
der impfstoff ist ja erst ab 18
zugelassen mein eindruck da hat die
politik auch noch gar keine idee dafür
man kann aber auch anders auf all das
schauen stichwort solidarität sollten
wir diese pandemie nicht alle gemeinsam
bis zum ende durchstehen jens spahn
wünscht sich dass das wir alle
solidarisch bleiben auch die die schon
geimpft sind muss man nochmals getragen
konnte dann immer ich bin ja auch jemand
der schon hatte sie allgemein bekannt
ich werde ich bin noch nicht eine
sekunde auf die idee gekommen zu sagen
weil ich schon hatte brauche ich keine
maske meer treiben weil ich das
irgendwie nicht angebracht finde in der
zeit wo für alle die regeln gelten dass
dann einige sagen ja brauche ich aber
nicht mehr ich ein nachweis dass das
führt doch nicht zum frieden
ja das klingt erstmal gut aber der wird
ganz praktische probleme geben denken
wir an einem ganz normalen linienbus in
der stadt die eine hälfte trägt eine
maske die andere hälfte nicht mehr oder
wer soll das denn kontrollieren in der
tat das beispiel mit dem bus wo man dann
nicht weiß wer trägt eigentlich eine
maske weil er das ablehnt und ist damit
gefährlich wer trägt keine maske weil er
geimpft ist und ungefährlich das
verdeutlicht dass da dann erhebliche ja
auch missstimmung hinein getragen würde
und deshalb ist es nachvollziehbar zu
sagen masken pflicht bleibt bestehen
die zweiklassengesellschaft die spaltung
der gesellschaft das ist ja das was
sparen befürchtet aber stimmt das darf
der gesangsverein echt erst wieder
singen wenn alle mitglieder geimpft sind
ich glaube wir können an der stelle auch
sagen wir wir können das denjenigen die
entsprechend diese voraussetzung nicht
mehr erfüllen dass auch die beschränkung
ihnen gegenüber nicht mehr gelten und
der gesangsverein ist ein gutes beispiel
wenn alle anderen geimpft sind außer mir
dann fände ich es eigenartig zu sagen
ihr müsst aber jetzt bitteschön auch zu
hause bleiben wer solange ich nicht
mitsingen darf dürft ihr auch nicht
singen das scheint mir eigentlich der
situation nicht angemessen ich glaube
auch nicht dass das der solidaritäts
vorstellung in der bevölkerung
entspricht
grundsätzlich wir sind bei diesem thema
echt noch ganz ganz am anfang
karl lauterbach findet das sei sowieso
viel zu früh sich jetzt schon damit zu
befassen
privilegien debatte bei geimpften dass
seine luxus debatte weil wir haben nicht
genug impfstoff und das wird ehrlich
gesagt die nächsten sechs monate so
bleiben ja aber ich finde ja die politik
muss trotzdem jetzt anfangen sich
darüber gedanken zu machen damit sie
dann wenn es soweit ist eine fertige
meinung dazu hat damit ist vielleicht
nicht so läuft wie beim thema schule
oder impfstoff beschaffungen ihr
erinnert euch was aber jetzt schon klar
ist bei diesem thema ist sich die große
koalition nicht einig also wir haben
gesehen er spricht vieles für manches
gegen eine frühere lockerung für
geimpfte aber zuallererst muss ins die
medizin die wichtige frage beantworten
bleibt man nach einer impfung ansteckend
oder nicht davon hängt alles ab wenn
nicht könnten geimpfte zumindest in
flugzeugen restaurants fußballstadien
und so weit ganz legal bevorzugt werden
nur der stadt darf keinen unterschied
machen zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften ich hoffe ich konnte dieses
komplizierte dinge für euch ein bisschen
sortieren ich weiß das thema polarisiert
aber gerade deswegen bin ich echt
gespannt auf eure meinung sagt uns wie
ihr es finden würde wenn geimpfte ihre
freiheiten früher zurückbekommen würden
also schreibt uns gerne in die
kommentare wenn ihr mögt und ich lese
mit und wir antworten auch und wenn ihr
gerne zugeschaut habt dann schenkt mir
doch ein like abonniert unseren kanal
und verpasst auf keinen fall die nächste
folge von inside politics wir verlinken
euch jetzt das video was ich euch
versprochen habe vom auslandsjournal das
zeigt wie israel mit der impfung lockt
und wenn euch das thema impfen generell
interessiert dann ist vielleicht auch
das hier was für euch 13 fragen zur
impfpflicht ja oder nein